[Music]
science can make a big difference
anywhere from just a simple reaction to
a big experiment if you just find the
right application science can save the
world
my name is catanjali rao i'm a scientist
this great big story was made possible
by
accenture
[Music]
i invented a device called tethys that
detects lead and water faster than any
other current techniques out there today
i was appalled by the number of people
affected by lead and water during the
flint water crisis i wanted to do
something to change this for the
residents of flint and places like one
all over the world
my device includes a core device and a
disposable cartridge with the carbon
nanotube sensor you dip this disposable
cartridge into the water you want to
test you pull out your phone open up the
tetanus application and connect over
bluetooth to get the results of safe
slightly contaminated or critical of
lead levels in your water
[Music]
my advice to other kids who want to save
the world is to not be afraid to try
i failed like four or five times but i
got back into the lab did again and then
it was like the aha moment when
everything kind of started coming
together
and you know the device is boring
i think that science allows me to look
at different approaches to solve real
world problems out there today it's
important to take other people's
problems and make something to help them
with it mainly because we're all one big
community and it's our duty to help
other people
[Music]
you